This is the beginning of the,
the French part of,
of the course,
because today I'm going to talk about,
uh,
the enlightenment and a,
the sort of the cultural concomitants of the French revolution,
I,
and sort of how people began to imagine an alternative sear or an alternate,
a sense of,
of sovereignty in the nation.
And then you're in for trade on Monday cause I had one of the only bootleg
copies of,
uh,
the,
the live speech and then the execution of Louis the 16th.
So I'm going to play that.
And also the death of citizen Mohan in the bathtub at the hands of Charlotte
called day.
Uh,
and so that'll be on,
on Monday.
And then I'll talk about inevitably,
but I don't particularly like him on Napoleon on a I on Wednesday.
Uh,
so the next three times for about labelle fos,
but because the revolution is,
is terribly important,
uh,
and uh,
indeed,
uh,
you know,
in lots of ways,
in many places as well.
We're doing.
So what,
I'm going to start,
I'm going to do three things today.
I'm going to first talk about four things.
First,
just your basic outline of what difference the enlightenment made a followed by,
uh,
with reference to my,
a good friend Bob Darwin's work.
Uh,
the social history of ideas and look at sort of surprising ways that
enlightenment influence,
uh,
was felt,
and not talking about the big time people like Lou,
so,
and Voltaire,
but the Grub Street hacks.
And then I'm going to talk a little bit about the public sphere.
Uh,
taking two examples.
One from the work of David Bell and one from the work of Sarah Mazda,
uh,
in which you can see the sort of emergence of,
of this possibly different way of viewing sovereignty,
it residing in the nation and not in,
in,
in a king.
And then look again at what kind of,
what difference,
uh,
in a very strange way,
the enlightenment I made in all of this.
So first to kind of classic,
a classic stuff just to review,
uh,
for you.
Um,
if you had to summarize six ways that enlightenment mattered,
uh,
you might indeed list them like this.
Uh,
first of all,
uh,
without question,
enlightenment thought,
although the enlightenment thinkers disagreed on many things and,
and a few were atheists,
but not many,
but most were deist and believe that God was sort of everywhere.
Um,
the enlightenment did weaken the hold of traditional religion,
particularly the role of the Catholic Church as,
as a,
as a public institution.
Uh,
in France of course,
if you read in high school French or,
or whatever,
uh,
wherever a candied,
which is blatantly a,
uh,
anti a religious of Voltaire,
you'll see the most extreme example of that.
Uh,
secondly,
and related to this,
um,
it,
the,
the Lightbend thinkers taught a secular code of ethics,
uh,
one that was a divorced from a religious beliefs,
that they were engaged with humanity.
They loved humanity.
They thought people were basically good and not,
and this shouldn't be just a valley of tears,
uh,
awaiting eternal life and went out,
to,
uh,
make,
such claims.
Third is that they developed a,
a critical spirit,
uh,
of analysis,
not to s not to accept routine tradition sort of passed out path.
A truth that were passed down from generation to generation.
Uh,
particularly those passed down by,
um,
uh,
by religious,
a religious establishment and not to accept routine,
uh,
a tradition.
I'm such,
for example,
a routine hierarchies,
uh,
that,
and this was part of,
of their,
uh,
of their spirit of analysis.
Fourth,
they were curious about history and believed they believed in progress.
Um,
and they were convinced that,
that,
uh,
that France had a special role to play in this.
And to be sure the enlightenment,
uh,
was to be found in many places in,
in,
in Europe,
uh,
and in,
the United States,
and it will,
it became the United States.
Uh,
but nonetheless,
uh,
Paris particularly played a central role in that,
um,
fifth that they differentiated absolutism from despotism.
And in order to understand,
you know,
what happens in this,
a remarkable series of events,
uh,
in a 1789 and in subsequent years,
as I said before,
there weren't 10 people in France who consider themselves Republicans,
uh,
that is wanted Republican's 1789.
And how it was that,
uh,
two or three years later,
well,
in 1793,
I became an easy,
uh,
for the majority of the population to imagine a life without any king at all.
And sixth,
uh,
that,
and here's the role of,
of the kind of the Grub street hacks of the kind of third division of,
of,
uh,
of enlightenment thinkers that we'll talk about it in just a few minutes.
Uh,
they,
they heap abuse against what they consider to be an unearned,
unjustified privilege.
Uh,
and,
uh,
how can we put this disrespected,
the monarchy.
Uh,
and indeed,
uh,
the nobles who,
who hung around,
uh,
the king,
so,
uh,
one can say in hindsight because we know what happened next,
that the enlightenment helped,
uh,
prepare,
other way for,
uh,
the French revolution and that the French Revolution Transferred Power
Transferred Authority to people who were very influenced by the enlightenment.
The classic example,
which I will give it because I enjoy talking about him so much and he has an
important as Mexico million,
uh,
Hovis piano,
who in many ways was a child of the philosophic as you know,
the philosophic,
which is such an important word.
I in French,
it became a word in English,
the philosophic,
a word,
the thinkers of the enlightenment and hubs.
Pierre,
uh,
born in a house in the northern part of France.
And now what is the product?
[inaudible],
uh,
was very much influenced by enlightenment thought I,
and,
uh,
the,
as the 12 of the committee of public safety sat around that big green table
making decisions that affected the lives of,
of lots of people in France.
Uh,
enlightenment influence,
uh,
is,
was certainly there.
Now the enlightenment,
you know,
stretched across frontiers.
Uh,
and if you,
if you do,
I think there's a map in the second edition of the book that you're kind of the
reading it that shows the,
uh,
how many,
where,
where you could find copies of Djo,
hose,
famous encyclopedia,
and you could find it in South Africa.
You could find it in,
in,
in Moscow,
you could find it in Philadelphia,
you could find it in New York.
Uh,
you could find it in,
in,
in paypal,
Rome.
You can find it all over the place.
Um,
but one thing that's,
that,
that's,
that's interesting is,
is that,
uh,
you know,
20 or 30 years ago,
so what I was sort of starting out and when people did what they used to call
intellectual history,
intellectual history was sort of the big ideas.
When you call it the kind of via Reggea of history where you've got one idea
sort of,
uh,
moving along and it sort of hooks up with another idea.
And then a,
then a third idea comes as a result of that idea.
And,
uh,
it's rather like traditional art history where you try to decide or discover
where it is that a,
you know,
Pizarro got his red ochre as a color or,
uh,
or where,
it was such a,
such a broke painter.
Uh,
uh,
got the idea of painting a,
a cherubs in,
in a certain way.
Now in the very early seventies,
my,
uh,
colleague,
retired a long time and greatest story in Peter Gay coined the phrase,
the social history of ideas,
that ideas to have a history.
I mean,
who,
who understood,
who sold,
who read Voltaire,
who read the Encyclopedia of Djo Ho,
uh,
how do we know how these ideas were used?
And so,
uh,
he called for the social history of ideas and a number of people,
including Bob Darton,
who's now at Harvard,
but I taught at Princeton for,
for decades,
and who turned out really the finest historians of,
of old regime France,
uh,
took this very seriously.
So did my,
another friend of mine,
Daniel,
Shh,
uh,
who,
did,
uh,
work on the academy,
which I'll discuss in a while.
So they began to look at,
you know,
how did enlightenment ideas get around?
I mean,
how did copies of Candide,
which was illegal in France,
censored?
How did these,
these things turn up in,
in France?
Um,
so let me just say a couple things about this.
Enlightenment ideas,
uh,
really came into,
elite,
popular opinion in,
in what we call the public sphere.
That is people who are interested in ideas and people who became interested in
politics in really three major ways in France.
Uh,
and,
and their,
their equivalent of these and other places.
The,
the Scottish example,
because the Scottish enlightenment is very important.
I mean,
you can read about it in the book.
Uh,
will,
uh,
one of these will be quite clear there first,
through academies,
uh,
Academy,
an academy a is not a university.
It has nothing to do with the university academy and they still exist.
I'm a member of one of these academy and obscure winning the Owl Dash,
uh,
in academy.
It was a group of sort of,
of Aryeh dights,
uh,
sometimes including clergy,
many nobles,
uh,
many kinds of,
you know,
bourgeois people of education who,
uh,
the population that was literate increases in,
in western Europe a decidedly,
uh,
in the 18th century.
And they would get together and they discuss ideas and they had contests,
uh,
where people who wanted to make them a little money would answer a question,
put out by the academy and they would write,
uh,
write responses to questions about,
you know,
about science and about religion and,
and about ideas,
big time ideas or it was piano who wins one of these contests.
And these academy meet in,
in,
in smaller rooms than uh,
than this.
But they discuss ideas.
And so I mean there with these ideas about,
you know,
of,
of sort of that are putting in Sharp,
uh,
analysis,
a reevaluation.
The role of the church I was institution,
they have to get around some way.
People have to know,
you know,
know about them.
And the academy is one way that this happened.
A second one moving to number three are masonic lodges.
A masonic lodge is still exists.
There's one,
I don't know if it's still active,
but there's a big masonic building out on Whitney on the right.
I think it became an insurance building.
And one of the,
you know,
the horrors of my seventh grade life was having to be dragged off to the dancing
school in Portland,
Oregon,
which meant it,
you know,
in a large building,
which was a masonic lodge.
Now Masonic Masonic Lodges Begin in,
in,
in Scotland and,
and they are secular secularizing,
uh,
institutions that,
that,
that the members,
you know,
uh,
mostly all agree that agreed in the 18th century that the Church has public
role,
institution role is,
is,
is to too important.
So masonic lodges talk about these ideas as well.
They talk about who,
so Ddo Montez too,
and all of these people.
And so this is a second way in which,
uh,
these,
these ideas get out.
And the third is the subtle.
There's another French word that's so important to became an English word.
[inaudible] was a gathering of,
of,
of pretty elite people,
but interested in the life of the mind.
They met in,
they were hosted by hostesses.
Again,
the role of women in the lightening.
And I give you in the book the example of Madame,
you'll Fra,
uh,
which was the classic one,
but people would come together to eat,
to drink and discuss ideas.
Uh,
you know,
when British guests came to,
uh,
Paris,
the salon,
and they said,
well,
all they do is and drink.
They spent all their time eating and drinking and they don't discuss ideas that
much,
but in fact they did.
And they're still a wonderful place in Paris called the,
uh,
pilot high Allah,
or you couldn't go.
And on very hot days in the 18th century and the 17th seventies,
you can imagine people meeting,
they're talking about the ideas of young enlightenment,
hot shots,
uh,
those people who have become part of the Canon,
you know,
of,
of Western,
uh,
of Western civilization.
Uh,
and so this is another way where these ideas get up,
get along.
And so young would be philosophic on the make coming up from the provinces,
what they want to just be introduced to one of these hostesses so that they will
be invited to trot out their intellectual wares at one of these gatherings.
So these are concrete examples of the way that these ideas got around and people
didn't pay any attention to this before about 30,
35 years ago.
Daniel hoelschers book on the academy,
two volumes to huge volumes not translated are really,
you know,
are really marvelous,
uh,
in,
in all of that.
So that's something to keep in mind.
Now.
Um,
now the,
the high enlightenment really,
you know,
really ends in 1778 traditionally that's a textbook kind of a,
but it doesn't matter because that's when Voltaire and his great enemy who so
both die.
Now after that,
there are no more multiple Jews are Voltaire's.
Uh,
or you know,
the,
the big,
the big time,
the all stars of,
of,
of the philosophic.
There aren't anymore.
But there is this next generation of would be Phyllis off people who could think
and who could write and who want to hit the big time.
And they,
they see the Voltaire made big bucks,
big frank,
big free fall,
a big lever,
uh,
writing.
And they want to be like him.
They want to be be like Voltaire,
or they want to be like,
who is,
so his arch enemy paced around his,
his little farm called [inaudible] met and sub wild outside of Shambo.
He and who hated Russo.
He hated Voltaire.
They really couldn't,
couldn't stand each other,
but he also hit the big time.
And so what the Grub Street hacks Grub street refers to,
you know,
so,
uh,
I don't know if it's a real street or imaginary street in London where,
where lots of would be writers and writers who are peddling their wares hung
around these grub street hacks.
The third division of people who want to have the kind of entry in the Sutton on
life to,
um,
to put forth their ideas.
Uh,
they live on the top floor of where the poorest people live.
They're dodging their,
their landlords all the time.
They don't have enough money to pay.
A lot of them live in Paris right around now that you're Odl,
it doesn't matter if you know,
or the oil,
but they live,
uh,
right around,
that part in the Latin quarter.
But more in,
in,
uh,
what now is the sixth,
on these small,
uh,
and they,
right.
But what do they write about?
They need to make money.
So,
uh,
the,
the big news here as Darton discovered is that they write,
they write pornography.
They,
right,
I go scatological for pornography.
They write what they call in French Lee better.
They were,
they write a broad sides really denouncing,
uh,
denouncing the royal family,
denouncing the queen above all in delicately called the Austrian horror.
By here many detractors who are omnipresent,
uh,
and,
they write against what they think is unearned privilege,
the kind of censorship that they see as keeping them from hitting the big time.
And so when the point of,
of,
of Darwin's many wonderful books is that in the long run are these people were
the Grub Street hacks,
uh,
Voltaire denigrated in them as the Kenai,
the rabble,
the scribblers jealous,
eager,
anxious,
hungry,
is that their attacks on the regime and against the unearned privilege as they
saw it helps a road belief in the monarchy and help suggest that the monarchy
itself and the people hanging around the monarchy had Versailles are,
is lapsing into despotism.
So they do make a difference.
Now,
let me give you an example.
This is sort of a classic one.
Imagine you're a bookseller in Poitier.
Poitier is a very nice town,
full of lovely old Romanesque churches in sort of the central western France.
[inaudible].
You are writing to Switzerland to order books that you want to sell to people
who have ordered books,
for example.
Uh,
and he writes the following letter.
Here's a short list of philosophical books.
You know,
books written by the philosophic that I want to order.
Please send the invoice in advance.
They include Venus in the cloister or the nun in the nightgown Christianity.
Uh,
unveiled that could be that,
you know,
the subtitle to memories,
the memories of a diamond.
Now my keys at the pump,
uh,
inquiry on the origins of Oriental despotism,
the system of nature,
Teresa,
the philosopher,
Margo,
the camp follower.
Now this is not exactly the stuff of Dj Ddo Voltaire who so,
and,
and these other people,
but yet those who penned such things,
imagine that they were Phyllis off and wanted to have the same kind of impact
that,
uh,
that Voltaire and the others,
had.
These were the,
those are the kind I either kind of rabble of,
uh,
of Grub street.
Now,
why was he writing Switzerland,
uh,
to begin with?
And again,
this is the,
this is again the question of how do these ideas get around.
Now,
one of the things that the GRUB street hacks didn't like is that you've got
sensors,
you've got paid sensors who worked for the government who says this can't be
published,
or Ah,
you shouldn't have published that baby.
That wasn't a good idea.
Um,
and so the result is it because in a system in which privilege of which
monopolies of which guilds controlled the production and distribution of almost
everything that book selling and book printing or monopolies controlled by the
state.
So you can't just,
if you're a Parisian printer,
you know,
unless you're risking being thrown in the slammer,
the,
you know,
in the slammer,
uh,
you,
and that's not a real word in French.
And I was like,
uh,
you,
you know,
you can't print this stuff out.
Uh,
in,
uh,
in Paris,
so much of a,
of the enlightenment literature is published in,
you'll not be shocked to know,
you already know this in Amsterdam or in Lusail in Brussels and the southern
Netherlands or in Switzerland.
And Bob Darren,
when he was a young,
a young professor before the young graduate student,
he hit the Jackpot because he gets a lot of the stuff was,
it was pretty early on in Switzerland in new Chatel.
And he got ahold of the Archives of this printing company.
So he was able to do the social history of ideas,
who bought what.
Oh by the way,
how do you get,
before there was Ryan Air,
uh,
or any of these places,
how do you get all of this stuff from Switzerland where there are big mountains
into France?
How do you get it to Poitier?
How do you get it there?
So again,
you have to look at the way that this stuff was distributed,
the ideas we've already seen,
how they were distributed,
but how literally you get these,
these books,
these Bukana,
these pamphlets.
He's brochure from Switzerland or the equivalent from Amsterdam or Brucello.
That's easier.
A flat country is a little different than mountains,
uh,
into France.
Well,
uh,
in France,
as in the German states,
as in Italy,
they were peddlers.
They were peddlers and what they went,
they would go on the road and they had,
you know,
like a medicine ball and a gym.
They'd have these huge leather bags and they'd be stuffed with all sorts of
things.
Pens and pins.
And I think I mentioned this in another context and you know,
uh,
religious,
literature,
but also a hidden at the bottom beneath the religious literature.
Uh,
they are,
are smuggling into France,
enlightenment literature and they have drop off,
drop,
drop off points.
Uh,
they go over the [inaudible] mountains that's not so easy to do.
And they take them to a city like shore mall in the east or Mez or a Nazi,
and then somebody else carries this stuff all the way.
So avoiding the police around Paris,
the,
the gendarmerie either Maasho say as they were called then it doesn't matter
that this stuff,
Venus,
the,
you know,
the camp follower,
Margo of the camp follower ends up pleasing this,
this,
uh,
you know,
drooling guy in,
in,
in Poitier who can buy it from his bookstore.
Um,
so,
uh,
the,
so I mean,
so when you can really follow,
not only need arose encyclopedia,
and how do we know where Dee Dee orocecal PD ended up,
by the way?
Well,
for example,
a people who leave wills,
you know,
uh,
well that's how we know about literature in the 19th century because people
wouldn't have the libraries I in in a states would be,
it would be detailed.
So we know what books people had.
Now in the 18th century,
we have a tremendous proliferation of ideas of reading,
of literacy and have ways of discussing these ideas.
I've already mentioned three of them there,
but if you look at the case of,
of,
of Britain,
you've got the coffee house,
coffee houses follow the mania of coffee and coffee comes from where the
colonies.
So coffee houses,
you know,
are part of,
uh,
this sort of globalization of the economy,
but also the globalization of ideas.
So this stuff all kind of fits together.
Uh,
so again,
uh,
the,
these Voltaire and Russo and Montas,
you and de Novo and the others would be just horrified to think that anybody in
intellectual,
we mentioned some of these grubs treat hacks along with them.
Uh,
because they didn't accept them and nor were they have the same quality at all.
Some of these guys,
by the way,
there's one who I mentioned the book,
a guy called,
we sold B R I s.
S OT,
uh,
who becomes an important leader of a faction in the revolution called digital
down from around Boldo who are against the Jacco van.
More about that later.
Bri.
So is broke.
How's he going to pay the landlord?
He has no idea where is he going to get his next drink.
So what's he do?
He worked for the police.
He works as,
as police informer on the other.
Phyllis would be philosophically,
I'm the GRUB street hacks.
How do we know this?
Darren found the dossier in which Reso is being paid off by these people.
How other,
what are other ways that we know how many of these characters there were there
about two or 300?
I don't remember exactly why.
Cause they want money.
So the on one hand they say,
oh,
I don't like this.
Censorship is keep keeping people,
keeping people from recognizing my true genius or their hand.
They write little sniffling letters saying I am a writer and a very good one.
Indeed.
And therefore I mirror at a state pension.
So they write these letters to various,
the equivalent of ministries saying,
please give me some money because I am a,
I am a really wonderful writer and,
and instead of repressing my work,
you should be saluting my genius.
And so they write no clammy,
uh,
letters like that,
that you find in the archives.
So we piece this stuff together,
uh,
gradually.
So let me just a race over here and just give you just an example of where is
this stuff.
All right,
here.
Here we go.
What would Voltaire think of this?
Um,
here is a one of these pamphlets that's denouncing the high livers that,
uh,
out at Versailles,
the public has worn that an epidemic disease is raging among the girls of the
opera,
uh,
that has begun to reach the ladies of the court and that has been communicated
to their lackeys.
This disease elongates,
the face,
destroys the complexion,
reduces the weight and causes horrible ravages where it becomes situated.
There are ladies teeth,
others without eyebrows,
and some are now completely paralyzed.
So people want to know what is it,
what's obviously have an year old disease.
And he's obviously exaggerating,
you know,
the,
uh,
don't,
who knows?
I mean,
I don't know,
but,
uh,
you know,
the results of such,
uh,
of such a melody.
But what,
what he's doing is he sees Justin that what's really going on at Versailles is
lots of people how to put this politely,
hooking up all over the places at the PTT,
you,
whether dressing up as peasants or whatever.
Uh,
and that the result is it is very demeaning for,
uh,
the French state and for the French monarchy.
So does this have an effect?
It does.
It really does.
And it leads,
it,
it contributes to what has been called the de sacralization of the French
monarchy.
That it's very hard to argue that God has put absolute monarchs on,
uh,
on earth to,
to make,
bring people better lives.
If you've got these people,
uh,
and no one had ever really ordinary people did not get into Joe Tsai unless they
were among the know,
the 15,000 lackeys working their lackeys would be the term given by the people
who employ them.
Uh,
you,
you know,
you didn't know.
So you had to surmise,
you had to guess what was going on.
And I'll give you a couple of examples in a while and I better hurry up and do
this,
uh,
in which you can kind of see how this works.
I'll give you a kind of a spectacularly interesting example.
He's,
I think so,
uh,
at the end,
no,
by the way,
just as an aside and w,
uh,
during the French revolution,
you know,
Louis the 16th size to get the hell out.
And so he and Marie Antoinette improbably dress themselves up as sort of a
ordinary people.
Uh,
and you know,
they're not people who have to set the alarm clock.
Usually they get up at three in the morning and they get into this.
This large carriage has been stuck stuffed with silver and flog off and all
sorts of other things.
And they hightail it toward what is now the Belgian frontier.
But they get further and further behind.
You can read about this when you get to that chapter.
It's a,
it's an interesting story.
And finally they get recognize.
Uh,
she is not a governance.
She is the queen.
Uh,
and one of the people that first,
uh,
realizes this,
the king has actually caught a glimpse of the king himself by looking through
the fence at just sigh at the time of a wedding and he sees the king.
There aren't photographs,
but he recognizes the king's nose and he gets done as knees and said,
[inaudible] you are the king and this guy can no longer pretend that he's Amir
hanger on with it,
you know,
uh,
assisting a Russian bareness.
Uh,
and it's all over.
But the shouting I at that point.
Um,
so,
uh,
what these people do is they helped break down the sense of automatic respect
for the monarchy as an institution.
And of course the fact that they can't stand a Marie Antoinette,
uh,
who rightly or wrongly is accused of all sorts of things.
Now this is a racing ahead of the story,
but,
uh,
Louis 16th was a big time cuckolded guy because his wife was seriously sleeping
around while he was putting a,
taking to get apart and putting back together clocks,
which he liked to do a in the big house when his wife is,
is,
you know,
out in the bushes.
Uh,
and to put,
you know,
crew crudely,
oh,
I forgot this is being held by some,
but anyway,
uh,
I take that back.
He race had fleas anyway.
Anyway,
so,
uh,
but what these people do is over the long run,
this helps a road,
uh,
you know,
respect for the monarchy and helps us explain why it was an in 1789,
you can imagine a world without a king and a world without a queen.
And when they bring them back,
they bring the old boy and his wife back from,
uh,
from violin,
which is in the northeast of France.
That national guard turns their backs and serious disrespect to the character
and they hold their guns upside down.
And at that point,
you know,
he,
he Lafonda I call it the end of the green beans as the French say for it,
for the king.
But this process started earlier and let me and the third string hacks of the
enlightenment had something to do with it.
And let me give you a couple of examples,
uh,
also from,
from,
from other friends,
but really good serious work been done in the last 20 or 25 years.
Now let me,
um,
uh,
rocketing right along here.
Um,
let me give you another example of this,
the relationship of the public sphere to imagining a new source of sovereignty
that is the nation.
And to give you an example of how that works.
And this comes from the work of David Bell,
who was my colleague and still very dear friend who teaches at Johns Hopkins.
Um,
and from,
from his work on lawyers,
uh,
in the 18th century.
So we'll see.
Give an example how,
sort of,
how this fits together now.
Um,
it also see it fits into enlightenment stuff because if,
if the enlightenment literature was censored and,
and sometimes hard to get,
uh,
to get ahold of though the encyclopedia was tolerated and not tolerated,
tolerated again,
um,
what,
uh,
Bell's work on,
on lawyers demonstrates is the way in which lawyers and legal briefs help get
these ideas around as well.
Because you could not censor legal briefs to give you just an aside.
Uh,
they don't worry about this.
Now,
uh,
in the case of imperial Russia,
in the late 19th century,
where there you had the big time censorship by the police,
uh,
in fact,
when there were these trials that were political trials,
uh,
lots of what,
what,
what was said in the courtroom got around as well,
and couldn't really be censored,
uh,
in a way that ordinary p,
publications could.
And so you had the same sort of effect there.
So let me give you a couple examples.
So they're,
they're,
they're complicated example,
but just don't worry about them.
Um,
the first would be from a,
this very strange,
not really heresy called,
uh,
but,
yeah,
I guess the Catholic Church considered a heresy called Jansenism.
I remember once coming in and do the equivalent of this lecture and having to
look at my own book for a good definition of Jansenism that I must've found once
because it's so obscure.
Uh,
there was a,
a bishop who didn't think he was obscure,
but a Belgian bishop,
uh,
who got called Janssen and cause y'all saw,
who thought that the Catholic church is becoming too overmighty and full of big
time broke masses and huge expenses for archbishops who were doing a damn thing.
And so he,
he,
uh,
I imagined another kind of religion that became very ascetic where it became
sort of like they were called somebody once called them Calvinists who went to
mass,
uh,
where they were still Catholic,
but they didn't believe in this or a high broke,
uh,
church.
And Janssen is him,
you know,
it's about in 17,
15 or so,
and then it comes back in the 1760s or 17,
seventies.
Um,
and it's extremely boring stuff now.
Louis the 14th,
and think it was boring,
he sent out the troops to burn down Jansen's Abby's the big was called Paul Ohio
outside of Paris because he thought that this was a threat to,
uh,
to the gala can church was with,
which is sort of the alliance of,
of,
of the Catholic Church,
uh,
with,
with the monarchy in France.
And so rather like Carthage,
they were supposed to plow salt into the land and all of this miss,
so they,
the business,
but they,
so they wage war on these chances,
just,
uh,
people,
um,
and um,
who were rather like Calvin has done many ways.
But the only point of that is that,
that there are lawyers who begin to defend the Jansen this and begin to see the
actions of the King Visa,
visa vi,
this persecuted religious minority as desk Spotify.
And so when lawyers are publishing legal briefs,
and there's enough references in the book so you can put this together.
But I just want you to see the point when they begin to publish legal briefs
defending the Jansenists against these kinds of attacks,
these are published in by thousands of them and they can't be censored.
And they begin to suggest at a time in the 19 in the 18th century,
particularly after mid century when we can already begin to speak of French
nationalism,
at least among the elite at the time of the seven years war,
1756,
1763 that's the seven years' war,
uh,
that it begins to suggest two things that monarchies can behave despotically
going beyond the limits of absolute rule,
the accepted limits of absolute rule,
uh,
and that,
that the,
that the nation,
this idea of the nation is being betrayed by bad governments.
And if this doesn't sound like the French revolution,
then nothing else will cause.
Those are very important defining moments.
Now,
the same thing happens also in the 1760s and seventies,
seventies,
which various attempts to liberalize the French economy that I described in the
book.
Um,
and uh,
the king's attempt to dispense with parliaments,
the part of the mall which were worse,
really a noble law courts that were provincial.
You can read about this,
but the same thing happens and this is the point is that these lawyers begin
turning out these legal briefs that imply two things,
the same.
Two things that absolute monarchy is risking,
stepping over the lines of the acceptable and behaving and despotic way.
And that there is something called the nation in which nobody ever imagined that
classes were all equal.
The discourse of Liberty Fraternity equality is a hell of a long way away,
but that the rights of the nation,
traditional rights of the nation are dying.
Being betrayed by the monarchy and the things ain't so good at Versailles.
And so again,
trying to look ahead and see what happens in 1788 and above all 70 89,
which he doesn't want to,
I'm not a big guy on dates and the history,
you have to remember all these dates,
but 1789,
like 1914 or late 1917,
that's a big one.
That's a big one.
Uh,
but in order to also understand the emergence of a radical republic and the
execution of the king,
uh,
one has to see that the nation becomes invested with a sense of moral quality.
That is,
that makes it,
it makes it not impossible to imagine a world without kings.
And so lawyers who are called barristers,
uh,
play a major role in all of this.
Now again,
this has to be seen in the context of a century in which more and more people
can read.
Now the,
the literacy rate in,
in,
in a country like France is still well below 50%.
Maybe it's a 40,
45%,
something like that more men could read than women.
But,
uh,
literacy not only literacy increases among,
among the elite,
but the amount of things that are published and the amount of newspapers that
are published,
uh,
that this expands dramatically.
Uh,
uh,
a point of reference would be in,
in,
in England,
and you can read it in Britain,
you can read about this,
but,
uh,
the campaign of John Wilkes who was sort of a,
you know,
have a rascally character,
uh,
but,
Wilkes and the number 45 becomes virtually illegal because 45 was the number of,
of,
of a newspaper,
uh,
in which,
Wilkes essentially and its supporters call out the English,
the British political system.
And so,
uh,
again,
we're talking mostly about western Europe and literacy is much higher and the
Netherlands and the,
and in northern France and in northern Italy and,
and,
and in England,
uh,
then,
then in other places.
But this is part of this cultural revolution that it's important to see the role
of this because,
you know,
Orthodox Marxist interpretation,
you had to have the ever rising bourgeoisie was either rising in the 14th
century.
There they are again in the 16th century there like some sort of runaway,
a bread or something like that in the 19th century.
There they are,
the bourgeois century.
I'll give a lecture on the bourgeoisie,
uh,
cause they do indeed rice.
But nonetheless,
you know,
it kind of class analysis can't be completely thrown out.
And me classes did exist and people had a sense of themselves as,
as being members of a,
of a social class.
I mean that's the way that it's not,
you know,
it was not immutable.
These boundaries were more fluid in a Britain,
in other places,
but,
but still is important.
But now for the last 30 years,
people had paid more attention to kind of the cultural competence of
concomitants of revolution and,
and what difference enlightenment ideas made and what difference to you and the
emergence of a sense of the nation.
Uh,
and the infusion of,
you know,
of politics with a sense of right and wrong and morality is that,
it's an important part of,
uh,
an important part of all this.
So let me in the last 12,
12 minutes and 30 seconds that,
that are,
uh,
that I,
that I have today.
Let me give you another example,
um,
uh,
of this,
and this is,
uh,
I think that,
you know,
a fascinating,
um,
uh,
let me find it so fascinating.
I can't find it,
but let me,
uh,
give me an example and this drawing upon an excellent book by Sarah Mazda.
It's a very well known episode,
uh,
but it shows you what kind of ties together the sense of the nation along with
the impact of the sort of third string of enlight you're third generation of
enlightenment hacks after 1778 to understand their role in the erosion of,
uh,
of a,
a sense of,
of,
uh,
that,
that the monarchy was immutable in representing the rights of a nation even as
that's construct was just coming into,
in,
into being,
um,
and,
and that in this book called,
uh,
what's it called?
Public life private affairs is,
I,
I'm bad on titles.
Maza takes a couple of,
of costs.
The lab costs,
the lab would be like,
one of the things that you find in the tabloids in Britain or the u s one of
these sort of,
I mean,
I don't read,
I don't read that stuff,
so I really don't,
can't give it a good example.
But you know,
one of these actors and actresses you always seen see running around or
whatever.
This,
this person is a Brittany Spears or something like that.
A singer,
actress.
I don't know what she does,
but,
but anyway,
uh,
but you know,
something like that,
that people focus their attention on these people.
Uh,
and they sort of dominate,
if you will,
this serve sort of a,
almost an insane comparison,
but the public sphere,
uh,
in that they're in the news all the time.
And so,
um,
what,
uh,
Mazda did about the same time that David Bell was working on,
on the role of lawyers in the 18th century is that she took a couple of these
examples,
uh,
and shows the way in which a private affairs that were,
you know,
kind of sleazy and,
and not too cool,
but were sensational,
uh,
help bring these threads together and,
contribute to erode,
uh,
the prestige of a,
of,
of the monarchy.
Now.
Um,
and this fits into,
uh,
the sense that have already given you that was extremely,
pervasive particularly around Paris,
is that a lot of the things that were adverse side weren't so good.
Uh,
and that,
you know,
that the 10,000 nobles who were clustered around,
uh,
Louis,
the 16th,
uh,
and particularly his wife,
were undermining the authority and the prestige of the monarchy and that wasn't
a good thing.
Um,
so an incident called the,
the,
the diamond necklace affair is illustrative and mildly amusing.
Not more than that.
It also involves this Palais Royale,
uh,
plus,
in Paris before a woman called John.
This sound funny me,
the name,
it doesn't matter at all.
Uh,
was a,
a poor,
poor,
noble.
Uh,
she'd claimed a cent from the royal family.
she had a pretty good education.
She had the important protectors,
and so she marries an ops officer of rather dubious,
a noble title,
uh,
who had called,
quite forgettable,
aided and Mackie did a Mutt.
Um,
he met the 50 year old cardinal called Louis Daryl Hall,
whose name I should have put on their R,
O,
h.
N,
who was from a very famous old family called wrong suebies.
The National Archives used to be,
uh,
in other,
adjacent to it and this fabulous old who,
God.
Why don't they ever have things that work in here?
It's just unbelievable.
Anyway,
I can't find the right with a family called the Ra.
Suebies.
Slu.
B.
I.
S.
E.
There's this fitness.
Wonderful,
wonderful,
uh,
um,
well palace,
really chateau in the,
my hae a w which is still there.
And this cardinal,
um,
is,
is on the make a,
he's very wealthy.
He's a cardinal.
That's why he's wealthy.
He's wealthy because he's,
because he's a cardinal,
he's also,
um,
he thinks he snubbed the queen.
He wants to be,
uh,
one of the people who help make important decisions.
Uh,
but,
um,
he thinks he's alienated the Queen,
that this is standing between him and,
uh,
and the power that he thinks he should have.
He writes,
he writes missives to the queen begging her to forgive him.
Um,
and uh,
he's met this Guy Della Moat,
and they begin sending forged replies from the Queen that suggests that,
uh,
you know,
the queen now is listening and maybe,
all is forgiven is going to be okay.
Um,
so,
um,
they have this idea.
Um,
they,
uh,
there's a famous jewel that had 647 flawless gems worth one and a half million
pounds,
uh,
which is a whole lot of money,
in those days.
And still now,
uh,
Louis the 15th had commissioned it for one of his mistresses and then back down
because it was too expensive.
Um,
in 1788,
the necklace was offered to Louis the 16th for Marie Antoinette,
but he turned it down saying the realm needs more ships than it does more
jewels,
which was reasonably reasonable.
Uh,
enough.
Now they con this,
this,
uh,
this old fairly horny cardinal to,
in to think into showing up at dusk,
at,
at the poly Royale and introducing him to the queen herself,
whom I guess he'd met once,
but it's dusk and his eyesight isn't that good.
And so what they do is they find this prostitute of which there are about 25,000
and in Paris at any one time,
uh,
who looks vaguely like Marie Antoinette.
And so this,
this cardinal do all sinks that his ship has come in,
that everything is going to be,
um,
uh,
is going to be okay.
And this purchase order has been forged,
supposedly signed by the Queen,
and the real jewels are,
are delivered.
And then of course,
it's broken up into pieces and sold on the street for,
you know,
for Zillions,
uh,
frank sold on the black market in,
in London.
And in Paris.
But there's a problem here because the word gets out what has happened,
and dual Raul who has really been made a fool,
there's this no doubt about it,
but it's more serious than that because what he has done is he has taken a,
he could be accused of Lez mushy stay,
which is just the ultimate kind of insult,
a plotting against the queen by identifying her,
a prostitute as the queen herself.
And so,
uh,
the monarchy,
to make it very long story short,
you know,
humiliated by all of this.
The cardinal is saying mass in his fancy robes,
uh,
in some cathedral probably signed you Stosh but I'm not sure.
It might've been know to dom.
I don't know.
Uh,
what was tiny.
Stacia isn't a cathedral.
But anyway,
he's in his,
his robes.
And so that they,
the police come in and they arrest him.
And so what happens then is they put him on trial.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
now he not a terribly lovable guy or not,
someone to be very much admired,
but by an incredible series of,
of,
of not incredible.
Uh,
a serious,
but by almost logical playing out of what I've been saying,
he did lawyers who defend him and the crowds who salute him portray him as a
victim of a regime that is crossing the line between absolutism despotism that
he is a cardinal and he becomes the darling of the people.
And of course,
poor old Jong,
the,
you know,
uh,
this noble,
I mean,
they,
she and her boyfriend get branded and their senators sent off to the galleries,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
uh,
predictably enough,
but,
uh,
the part,
of Paris a quits,
the good cardinal and he emerges from,
uh,
the Palace of justice or from the part of the mall still now on the,
that I the same,
the largest of the them three,
but now two islands in the sin to a popular acclaim saying that he,
that,
that justice and the interests of the nation have been served by his acquittal.
So what this sleazy,
uh,
incident does unsavory incident,
does is it can,
it helps erode a,
it helps continue the decentralization of the French monarchy.
And again,
lawyers and the people who see themselves as representing the interests of the
French nation are in their own imaginary and,
and their own mental construction.
And in,
uh,
in the eyes of,
of people who follows these,
these events in legal briefs and in newspapers,
the guy he's acquitted,
he seen as,
as,
as somebody who,
uh,
had been done wrong to buy a monarchy that has gone too far and that exactly,
not much more than a year later is what it's going to play out in the French
revolution itself.
So to conclude,
Voltaire get Home Montesquieu who you've been reading,
and these folks have big time impact on,
on the way we look at the world around us.
Uh,
and they had an impact on those people who would,
would,
would become the organizers of the revolution and indeed are the leaders of
France,
uh,
and their children,
their successors in the 19th century.
But lawyers,
uh,
part of this sort of culture of,
of,
uh,
increased,
public sphere,
uh,
that was western Europe in particular,
but also parts of the rest of Europe too in the 18th century.
Uh,
had a,
had a role in all of this,
uh,
and that bias by 1789,
not in any kind of inevitable process.
A revolution was not inevitable,
but the sense that the monarchy had gone too far and that there was something,
the nation out there,
ah Hah,
uh,
was in the public sphere.
And the results of,
of all this would be there to see in,
in 1789.
Now I have a good weekend,
and on Monday,
uh,
you're going to hear it.
The execution of the king,
the death of citizen Maha in his bathtub.
And then I hope to make clear why some people supported the revolution and
others didn't.
And what difference it all made.
So have a great weekend.
See you.